Nói 2,5 tần sau năm 2018, tông tin từ công an tình đất lắc.
Đơn vị đã ra quy định khởi tố của an hình sự.
Khi định khởi tố viết cân và lệnh tạm giang đời với hỏng phức tấn,
2 mì sau tuổi, chú tài xa ía là tình đất lắc.
Để điều tra về các hình viết, giết người và hiếp giấm.
Ná nhân là chỉ về tên lượng, bố mi tối, chú tài xa ía là tình đất lắc.
Là người bị hiếm phức về chỉ tuổi.
Chứ đó, vào sáng 12,5 tần sau năm 2018,
phòng cảnh rất hiện sự công an tình đất lắc với bệnh màu cao của công an xa ía
nà về việc phát hiện chỉ lơ từ công tại cú tụi bố miếp địa thôn đời kết.
xa ía nà trong tình trạm có nhiều giống hiệu bất thường.
Bởi tình thần khình chưa, quy định lượng công an đã nhìn trong xa liện hoàn phức bấn là đối tưởng như
bánh và sự tập đến cơ quan công an làm việc, tại cơ quan đường tra, tấn đã thường nhận hình vi phạm tổ.
Kết quả đối trạm bức đầu xác định, lối tượng đã nhiều lần lợi giống việc đã nhìn bị khiến khức về chỉ tự tự thiện hành vi phạm tổ.
Đến trở tối hệ 1 tàng xong năm 2018, lối tượng tiếp tục giữ rỗ nạn nhân đe khu vực nói trên bởi gái an, khiến nạn nhân từ vòng.
Hình cơ quan kính xác điều trạm công an tình đất lắc đang tiếp tục công của hồ xưa xưa liên nhân đối tượng theo quy định của phát lột.